Venezuela not to be confused with
Venezuela because that is the hot new
celebrity couple that sells Ben Affleck
Abu Salem is the country famous
for giving the world oil seven Miss
Universe yz6 Miss World and of course
most importantly one Wilmer Valderrama
who I like to think of as the Miss
Universe of that 70 show now over the
last few years it seemed like every time
Venezuela has been on the news it's
because something awful has been
happening food riots and looting this is
now the only daily diet Venezuelans can
count on violent protesters storm the
National Assembly Sunday even punching
some lawmakers chaos in Caracas is
stolen police helicopter fires on
Venezuela Supreme Court the clashes in
Caracas between protesters and police
are looking more like all-out war it's
true things in Venezuela have been
extremely grim so fair warning here this
is not going to be one of those
feel-good last week tonight stories like
slippers or everything looks okay the
pudding factory or a genocide but it's
only happening to balloon animals and it
has been hard to keep up with events in
Venezuela due to the hurricane of
that we've all been dealing with here
although if you follow a conservative
media at all you may have seen it
frequently painted as the inevitable
dire consequences of a socialist
government for a case in point just
watch this Infowars reporter quizzing an
extremely chill Bernie Sanders supporter
well you know Venezuela right a majority
of the country is currently eating rats
while their politicians are drinking
champagne on daily basis oh I'm saying
since if Bernie Sanders were president
right and he wanted to bring the same
ideas as social for socialism into this
country don't do you think that we would
benefit yeah
but I just told you Venezuela is getting
rats
but I just want build-up healthcare I
don't want like worms in your brain
honestly reporter she certainly just got
served by sassy Popeye what'd you do up
there is a nice distillation of the
current level of political discourse in
America to people who don't really know
what they're talking about condescending
to each other nonsensically until one of
them lands are sick burn but what is
happening in Venezuela it's not just
extremely important it is absolutely
worth paying attention to because this
is not just a story about socialism
there are plenty of socialist countries
that look nothing like Venezuela it's a
story about epic mismanagement so epic
that a nation of 31 million people with
the largest oil reserves in the world
have been forced to resort to some
pretty creative forms of protest social
media ablaze for the past few days
encouraging protesters to fill jars and
bags with human feces this is one of our
last options says this masked man we are
calling it who boot up cocktails yes who
boots off cocktails named of course
after the Soviet premier VI just laughed
pooper tov who was infamous for pooping
in jars and throwing other people a
little bit of history for you there and
well well that is funny because you know
it's poop it is also desperate people
resorting to a desperate measure and
given that next Sunday Venezuela is
having their presidential election
tonight we thought we'd check in on
what's been happening there to try and
understand how Venezuela got into this
mess and how despite making it even
worse their current president Nicolas
Maduro seen here
absolutely going to town on an honor is
almost certainly going to win despite
having the support of only around a
fifth of the population and to
understand anything about present-day
Venezuela you only have to start with
Maduro 'he's predecessor hugo chavez
shown here looking understandably smug
about the fact that he's got a bird in a
hat on his shoulder
now Chavez was massively popular in
Venezuela beloved for both his generous
social programs and his larger-than-life
personality every Sunday he staged
marathon TV broadcasts that sometimes
ran up to eight hours on his show
although Presidente the show featured
special guests dance numbers and prize
giveaways over here we have flat-screen
TVs it's the opposite of capitalism
because if giving away flat-screen TVs
is truly the opposite of capitalism and
the most successful socialist leader in
history is comrade Roux Kerry now Chavez
could act the way that he did because
Venezuela was oil-rich and over the
course of his presidency he took more
and more state control over their
national oil company enabling him to
fund programs benefiting the poor and
when that company protested some of the
changes that he was making he responded
by using his TV show to address its
executives directly there Peter I'm
firing the following people mr. Juan
Fernandez you are fired from petroleum
of Venezuela Eddie Ramirez thank you
very much
you were fired also Mariano Rodriguez
you are not fired but if you don't stop
talking to your boyfriend on
speakerphone you absolutely will be and
Mateo Martinez if you use the office
kitchen to microwave fish one more time
so help me I'm going to have you
murdered now to be back to the theater
Chavez many of his social programmes
were initially effective during his
tenure the poverty rate was nearly
halved and to this day many Venezuelans
revere Chavez to a dramatic degree the
late president's eyes are painted on
public buildings as if watching over the
revolution this man even chattering the
eyes onto his foreign
that's the image the eyes of our supreme
commander
Hugo Rafael Chavez Frias the eyes that
see the world the whole world now that
is dedication right there I like my
president so much I want him to watch me
masturbate for the rest of my life
because that's what those eyes are going
to see that they'll see other things but
they're also seeing that and the thing
is some of Chavez his programs could
have been sustainable if he pursued a
sound economic policy and run a tight
ship but not only did he stop saving oil
revenues in a rainy day fund he also
oversaw a government that transparency
international found to be the most
corrupt country in Latin America and
remember Latin America has Columbia in
it a country where the only campaign
finance lawyers please report all bribes
consisting of more than 10 kilos of
cocaine still as long as the price of
oil went up forever and Chavez never
died the cracks could have been papered
over
unfortunately in 2014 the price of oil
plummeted from over $100 a barrel to
just $50 a barrel just one year after
Chavez plummeted from being alive to be
very much dead and here is where Maduro
the big banana fan comes in because
because he was Chavez his hand-picked
successor but unfortunately had neither
his booming economy nor his charisma
although he has desperately tried to
make up for that even going so far as to
tell people that he'd received messages
from the spirit of Chavez who visited
him in the form of a little bird it's a
story he's told repeatedly and sometimes
even frozen sound effects he repented
from Pajarito Chicopee Co Emilio
Travolta a guerilla
say peruse Notah Begay midi rocky in
peaceful silver your senti a pity to it
Nocenti a komodo know the hold our wind
assume now what i like the most about
that other than the whistling which are
like very much is is the idea that when
powerful leaders die they become birds
because that is a pretty humiliating
second act I led my people to greatness
and now I will buff my lunch into my
child's mouth and fly into a glass
window
look I don't want to say that murderers
charm offensive hasn't been working but
just watch this moment from a TV
appearance where he was reading messages
from viewers live on air company Moises
daveed tells me nicolas maduro suck on
it you suck on your own
but you could suck yourself yes that's
right
Maduro essentially appeared on a segment
of celebrities read mean tweets
completely by accident and the thing is
it's easy to see what Maduro has pissed
people off because he has managed
Venezuela's economic crisis in the worst
possible way he's doubled down on many
of Chavez most unsound policies like
unrealistic currency and price controls
while attempting to make up for missing
revenue by simply creating more money
and as a result inflation has exploded
with the IMF forecasting 13,000 percent
inflation for 2018 and and to give you
an idea of just how ridiculous that can
look this was a trip to a Venezuelan
market last year the currency is so
devalued some shopkeepers weigh the
money rather than waste time counting
and if residents are lucky enough to
find food on the shelves prices are out
of sight this plantain cost what your
house costs 25 years ago Wow
I mean there's clearly two options there
inflation is completely out of hand or
that is one incredible plantain I mean
world-class plantain an inflation is
just one of many reasons why why many
Venezuelans are struggling to find or
even afford basic necessities like
medicine or food and those shortages
have had some terrible consequences this
food shortage is widespread over the
last year three-quarters of the
population has lost an average of almost
20 pounds look how fat I used to be this
is how many holes I had to make in my
belt on the Maduro diet yes the Maduro
diet that is actually now a commonly
used phrase in Venezuela and it's a very
healthy sounding term for a truly
horrifying situation
he's one saying Jim Jones was the
pioneer of the Jonestown juice class
and and it is it is not like Maduro
isn't aware that people are starving in
fact during one of his media appearances
a reporter noticed that the video feed
cut away everytime Maduro helped himself
to the plates of charcuterie and cakes
so he knew that eating would look
insensitive although those camera
cutaways haven't always worked because
just watch this clip that went viral
last year and know that that what he's
saying here doesn't matter what's
important here to remember is he's about
to think that the camera is off him yeah
he just housed an empanada in front of a
starving nation and come on Maduro
a nationwide famine is no time for
fourth meal and if you think that is the
most tone-deaf reaction to Venezuela's
mass food shortages just wait until you
see him do some pretty insensitive crowd
work oh yeah why are you so skinny
Gustavo have you been jogging what
happened to him Maduro is diet Maduro is
diet makes you hard
ah seeing this is no need for Viagra wow
that is the most awkward presidential
attempt to be in on the joke since
Herbert Hoover claimed that Hoover towns
make you wet without the need for
cornmeal or castor oil they they they
didn't totally understand how vaginas
works back then and even even when the
Maduro government has tried to help it's
done it in a truly ham-fisted way for
instance Maduro has proposed a so-called
rabbits plan basically a program to
encourage Venezuelans to breed and eat
bunnies but when people started putting
bows on them and keeping them as pets
instead his administration gave a pretty
callous correction a rabbit is not a pet
it's two and a half kilos of meat that
is high in protein with no cholesterol
holy a rabbit is just two and a
half kilos of meat that sounds less like
a government pronouncement and more like
a tank top Marlin bando used to wear
back in his clubbing days policy Maduro
has generally lived in complete denial
his most recent plan to address rampant
inflation was to introduce a new version
of their currency the bolivar just with
three zeros lopped off the end and in
case any part of you thinks that might
actually fix their inflation problem we
asked a Yale economist Robert Shiller if
that's how money works take a look no
that's not how many works thanks Robert
thanks
in the absence of solutions Medora has
reached for the next best thing
blaming someone else over the years he
suggested that the United States was
responsible for injecting Chavez with
cancer he said that the u.s. was
sabotaging Venezuelan ATMs and he's
chalked up protest against him to this
former party lucuma this is part of a
scheme of non-conventional war that the
US has perfected throughout recent
decades okay so here's the thing there
America has undoubtedly done some awful
things in Central and South America
we've backed coup attempts hunters and
atrocities in Chile Argentina and
Guatemala but refreshingly was happening
in Venezuela is actually not our fault
accusing America of creating Venezuela's
crisis is about as fair as accusing OJ
Simpson of murdering Princess Diana I'm
not saying it will be completely out of
character
it just happens to not be true in this
particular instance so that's like
basically what I'm saying and yet and
yet despite all of this Maduro is about
to dominate this election like he
absolutely dominated that banana so how
is that possible well he's basically
bent Venezuela's democratic process to
his will back in 2015 when his party
lost control of the National Assembly he
responded by stacking the Supreme Court
with 13 new justices and then simply
created a whole new Assembly President
Nicolas Maduro wants to create a
political assembly with vast power to
rewrite the Constitution and potentially
dismantle the democratically elected
legislature all of the candidates today
are Maduro supporters including his wife
and son now just just think about the
sheer scale of what Maduro did there
that would be like if here Trump put a
bunch of his friends on the Supreme
Court who then happily allowed him to
create a second Congress that outranks
the real Congress and his members
include Melania and Erich and which by
the way you just know he'd called Andris
you know
and you know it and please take that
down before he gets any ideas I already
regret bringing it up now on top of that
majora has either jailed or barred from
public office a number of his political
opponents and has even turned down help
from other countries and agencies
including food and medicine he has
turned down food and medicine telling
Venezuela's that humanitarian aid is
part of a conspiracy to overthrow his
government all of which has let
Venezuelans feeling so hopeless that
nearly 1 million of them have left the
country over the past two years and many
of those who've remained and now at
their breaking point
[Music]
don't even take an Omaha
or que no tiene la mano mano colectivo
whatever
that's absolutely horrifying and when
you listen to her it starts to hit you
that pooh-poohed off cocktails might
actually turn out to be pretty
restraint and the most frustrating thing
here is there aren't a lot of great
options to help the Trump administration
has imposed some sanctions and is
considering more but if they're not
extremely careful those could wind up
causing even more hardship so at this
point
seeing as Maduro won't listen to reason
or to the will of his own people perhaps
it's time to call in the one voice that
we know he'll listen to so ladies and
gentlemen please welcome Herbert
[Applause]
[Music]
hola my ludo it's me a bird remember we
spoke a few years back okay and if
you're thinking this is just one more
Balderrama in a bird suit well used to
think it was Hugo Chaves you're not
exactly the authority on what birds but
listen up buddy because I'm two and a
half kilos of high protein and meat and
I'm here to tell you you're in some
serious trouble compadre it's not a good
sign when the people are throwing their
poop at you I should know I'm a bird
come on man I invented the poopoo table
cocktails yeah that's right every time a
bird poops on you you should know it was
a political statement
also that we aim then I thought it was
funny
Maduro the whole world can see what mess
you are making even TV hosts here in
America like that idiot
[Applause]
because it's bad timing Zazu
the point is Maduro you need to accept
humanitarian aid and and cool it with a
dictator stuff where I've got a poop
with tough cocktail with your name on it
right here alright this is it for me and
because I am a real actual bird I'm
going to exit with effortless beauty and
grace
[Music]
[Applause]
you